This is a production of Cornell University.
I was six years old when I brought
my first cucumber to my mother.
It was withered yellowing and approximately five
or six inches in length. But the immense pride I
felt was unshaken. Watching the tendrils from the
cucumber plant curl around the trellis I provided
for it was the first time I was consciously aware
of having a love of nature. Can you believe a 5,
000-year-old traditional farming technology has
a place in today's high-tech greenhouses. My name
is Jonah Helmer and I'm a sophomore at Cornell
University majoring in plant sciences with a
concentration in sustainability and a minor
in nutritional sciences. By the year 2050,
we're going to need to double the world's food
supply in order to feed our growing population.
My interest in sustainability has led me to
research aquaponics as a possible solution
to this problem. I've worked in research projects
that assess the difference between hydroponic and
aquaponic growing methods. I'm also the vice
president of the Cornell Hydroponics Club.
I hope to use these experiences to
build a career growing sustainable,
nutritious, and affordable produce in
greenhouses accessible to urban populations.
Hi. My name is Becky Stup and I'm a student
at Cornell. I was first on to plant science
because of one of the main issues facing society
is food insecurity. I've long been interested in
plant pathology and I feel like by studying the
genetic basis of disease resistance in plants
Ii can then apply that knowledge using gene
editing technology to improve crop yields
and therefore increase the whole amount of
food available to general public. However,
I've noticed a huge disconnect between
the public and scientists. People don't
know where their food is coming from or anything
about the technologies being used to produce it.
This is especially evident when it comes to GMOs.
A recent survey of consumer attitudes found that
ideas such as they're injecting toxic hormones
into our foods are still distressingly common.
Therefore I want to study science communications
and outreach techniques on top of my plant science
education so that i can be more adequately
prepared to educate the public throughout
my career. I realize there's so much more to
understand about the complex relationships between
plants and soils and microbes that live in the
soils and trees and humans. Hi. I'm Macy Smith.
I'm a freshman plant sciences major at Cornell
University. I'm from Cleveland, Ohio, which is
where I first was interested in plants. I had
an internship at Cleveland Botanical Gardens and
it was there that I realized how much I enjoyed
working with and being around plants. Then last
year, I had the opportunity to travel to Belize
with my science class, which is what solidified
my choice to study plant sciences. There, we
met a woman named Aurora. Aurora was called on
by her uncle her village's healer in their Mayan
community to become the village's next healer.
Hi, my name is Michael Morinski and I'm a freshman
here at Cornell University. One of the reasons why
i really love plants is just waking up in the
morning and seeing how much they've grown since
last day. Several studies have shown the benefits
of plants on mental health. But i also want to
examine the multiple benefits of plants on your
physical state. I want to bring that relationship
between humans and plants to the medical field and
I hope to attend a medical school post-graduation.
The simple activity of helping my family kind
of garden in our backyard built a long-term
connection. As a Cornell student, I hope that my
hands will look as old as they are meant to be.
Hi. I'm Victoria Mock and I'm currently a plant
science student here at Cornell, also seeking
minor in business. I grew up in northern
California and so I'm well aware of scarce
resources involved in agriculture, specifically
water in this case, and the challenges they pose
to efficient and healthy crop production. I just
recently started learning about indoor vertical
farms but already the idea of transforming a
space where there is virtually nothing into
somewhere where you can grow crops efficiently is
so appealing to me, mainly because each resource
can be tailored exactly to each plant need and
external factors such as a changing climate
and other difficulties like that are essentially
gone. These facilities are also highly sustainable
because the need for fertilizers and pesticides
is limited. In the future I would love to work for
one of these standard vertical farms helping
to improve their crop quality and health
while also combating economic challenges such
as input costs and facility management. Hey,
my name is Eddie Almanza I'm a freshman at
Cornell University pursuing a major in plant
sciences and a minor in business. I'm from
Trenton North Carolina which is very rural
and very dependent on agriculture. Since there
were so many agricultural jobs, I began working
on farms and with various crops such as tobacco,
sweet potatoes, cucumbers, and soybeans. For these
crops, I mainly just walked behind a tractor
replanting the crop or walking through a field
pulling out weeds and suckers. Eventually
I went on to work for a farmer and hemp.
We grew and harvested the hemp in a greenhouse and
the attention to detail to the pH, temperature and
amount of light needed was incredibly interesting.
This led me to realize that I wasn't interested
in plants just because I could make money.
But I was interested in plants but because
they were so interesting the way they grew
and that we can control the factors that
determine how they grow. Hi. My name is Lior
Cole and I'm a freshman at Cornell University.
Ever since I was little I had a fascination
with plants. And as I grew up I was diagnosed
with celiac disease, which only increased that
fascination. I learned that the wheat crop was
being genetically engineered in Spain to grow
as a sort of gluten-free wheat, which really
piqued my interest. So in high school, I started
a plant-focused club and I got involved with
research. Hi. My name is Lexi Mantilla. I'm
a current plant science major at Cornell and
what attracted me to this major was a research
experience i had in Wapusk National Park which is
45 kilometers south of Churchill, Manitoba.
Interestingly Churchill has a larger polar
bear population than human population. So
this was the first time in my life that i was
in a place that was largely untouched by humans.
It was just miles and miles of land that had
all this natural life and natural beauty and it
was the first time in my life that i was exposed
to all the complexities of the interactions
of all these different forms of life and
how they come together. I also learned
about what can happen when when one of
these elements becomes unbalanced and how this
could affect people living in that environment.
Hi. I'm Ben Polson. One of my earliest memories
is my dad and I trying to grow a tomato seedling
in our backyard. I was only three and he's from
the city so we had no idea what we were doing.
The plant died really quickly because
we put it in the shadiest spot possible.
After that I was inspired to actually grow
plants correctly. I would read seed packets
really diligently and plan out all my gardens on
graph paper. My gardens got better and better and
in high school I worked at Wegmans and a community
farm where I learned the more industrial side of
agriculture. That inspired me to become a plant
sciences major at Cornell University and I want
to focus on horticulture and more specifically
Controlled Environment Agriculture because i
think it would be great to provide sustainable
fresh produce to cities all around the world.
Plants are a vital part of the medical field from
pharmaceuticals to their mood boosting abilities
and I hope to study the relationship better and to
learn how to apply this knowledge towards medical
field to improve health care and to bring a
new perspective into the field. Thank you.
Hi. My name is Victoria Zhang and I am a
plant science major planning to concentrate
and plant breeding and genetics. Plants have
been involved in some of my favorite memories.
I remember being a kid helping my dad in the
garden and being so proud when I picked my first
homegrown tomato. Ever since then I've always
been my happiest when working with plants. But
I never really got into the scientific aspect
of it until one day two of my [unintelligible]
were flowering at the same time and i decided
to cross-pollinate them to make my own hybrid.
Well that failed but I'm still really glad I tried
because it opened my eyes for the world of plant
breeding. And at Cornell I realized how much
we rely on it. Scientists in the field have to
respond to all different kinds of pressures from
our changing culinary tastes to new trends and
ornamental plants and ultimately the future
of our food supply threatened by disease.
My name is Justin. I'm currently a sophomore
here at Cornell. Ever since I could walk I was
completely captivated by plants and when I was
10 or 11 I remember I got my first job sweeping
the floors of a greenhouse down the road from
where we lived and that was enough to like blow
my mind. And then that's how I saved enough money
-- I was about 13 -- I built my first greenhouse
and became like a certifiable [unintelligible].
That's kind of my history. As my interest grew
over the next five or so years I decided to
come to Cornell and major in plant science.
Coming here with the best resources offered
was just kind of like the natural next step
and for with the rapidly changing climate as well
advances in plant biology are exploding in demand
so for me personally concentrating my studies in
evolution and understanding how plants involved
in the past I feel a reliable model for predicting
how they can be best modified for the future uses
of society. Thank you. Hi. I'm Luke Johnson. I'm
a freshman studying plant sciences at Cornell.
I first got into plants simply by gardening with
my mom and my dad at home. Every year I'd ask my
parents to make the garden bigger and bigger.
That's what happened. I decided to study plant
science in college because I think we rely so
heavily on plants and there's so much potential
for what can be done with them. There's lots of
problems facing the world like climate change,
population growth, changes in eating habits.
And developments in new plant technologies are
really going to be necessary in the future and
I think it's the plant scientists that can make
that happen. Hi. My name is Hannah Rudt and I'm
a freshman studying plant sciences at Cornell's
College of Agriculture and Life Sciences. I grew
up in New York City in a household that really
valued hospitality and bringing people joy through
food. But growing up in New York City I also saw
the effects of food deserts and not having access
to affordable and healthy food. So with a base
in plant science as well as an understanding of
food distribution, public policy, and nutrition,
Ii'm really hoping to bring my passion to tangible
change in urban areas which are places that i
love. Hi. I'm Steven Espresso and I'm a plant
science major at Cornell from El Paso Texas.
Nitrogen and phosphorus are two of the main
components of fertilizer. And currently, though
mostly synthetically produced and mined. But
every day we excrete millions of pounds of these
nutrients in our urine. And all it does is go to
waste and pollute our drinking water. If you could
divert urine which is just one percent of all
sewage waste farmers could use this as fertilizer
this would be really beneficial because it would
conserve water and localize fertilizer production.
This has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu